what is your view on bible
versions my view on bible versions
a very serious one revelation 12 9 the bible
says listen carefully let me pray again father
please direct my thinking restrain my carnal
nature let me seek your glory please in
jesus name amen revelation 12 9 says listen
carefully and the great dragon was cast out
not all serpent called the devil and
satan which deceived the whole world
now he's called the great dragon that's a
destroyer serpent deceiver satan adversary
devil satan's slander devil adversary i believe
each name gives a different side of his character
and the way he works remember zachariah 3
verse 1 and he showed me joshua the high priest
standing before the angel of the lord
and satan standing at his right hand
to resist him he's an accuser and he's
an adversary devil satan serpent dragon
but even though all four names are given
only one quality is stressed listen again
and the great dragon was cast out the other
serpent called the devil and satan it doesn't
say which destroys the whole world which deceiveth
the whole world the devil's most effective tactic
is as a deceiver not a destroyer or an accuser
or slanderer a deceiver because deception is
so subtle it walks right next to truth now in
order to deceive you have to twist truth are
you following me the devil lied in heaven listen
to god jesus christ in john 8 44 ye are of your
father the devil and the lust of your father you
will do he was a murderer from the beginning and
abode not in the truth because there is no truth
in him when he speaketh a lie he speaketh of his
own for he is a liar and the father of it speaketh
of his own means lying is his natural language
lies originated with satan and lie is the
object of truth and god's law is truth god's
word is truth the devil deceives by twisting
the word of god he tried it on adam and eve he
succeeded he tried it on jesus he failed now if
this is the case satan must have his versions
i'm not here to identify them but i'm
telling you satan must have his versions
one of the reasons why no version is perfect but
all contain enough truth for someone to be saved
but some contain some dangerous translations for
instance one version in the what you call what
chapter where jacob is blessing his sons and the
bible says he leaned upon the top of his staff
the he worshipped leaning on his staff one
version says he worshipped the top of his staff
that's worshipping idols and one version says
of james 5 16 confess your sins one to another
james 5 16 says in the king james version confess
your faults now the catholics will accept confess
your sins because the priests are supposed
to con forgive sins so the version you choose
particularly if you're not theologically what's
the word trained is very very important i was
talking to a bible scholar and i asked
him if you could only use one version
to defend the fundamental teachings
of this church which would it be
and he said the king james version
if you can only choose just one
and many of them are good don't misunderstand me
but if you are restricted to one when you read
the books that are attacking the sanctuary they
almost they seldom use the king james version
very seldom use the king james version it is my
preference i don't preach it for anybody it is my
but i'm saying as a general statement say have you
ever heard of the the king the queen james version
there is the queen james version i believe that
version has changed only about eight verses
verses that deal with homosexuality have
been changed to make it more palatable to
those who practice that lifestyle now is that
aversion yes is that god's version how well
the version paraphrased but people still see it
as a bible there's a bible where you don't have
he he he forgot you have she it's a feminine
is that the version of god you have to decide
and show me in the bible or in the original greek
where god and hebrew where god is presented as she
all i'll say to you is my personal preference
i preached to no one is the king james version
and if i had to use one version to try to defend
the fundamental teachings of this church it
would be that version so that's just mine
i'm not trying to tell you what to do but i
will say this satan must have his versions
the reason why when the king james came
out the catholic church did not like it
next question amen
you